[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
history is going to change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for today
Oh slurp delicious now the reason I
drink the triple chick in the morning
because I get so dry from talking so
much nothing the show but from yelling
at my wife poor hand kylie yelling and
passionate its replacement for kisses
with us and the temperature who clears
the palate seltzer water you know that
with Scrubbing Bubbles soap that's what
you say is my thing it's what I know
dinerral I support before I introduce
everybody of course I do want to let you
know that we will have exclusive content
of oil available for Mudd Club members
like another hour of the show but a lot
with CARICOM slash mug Club $30 off for
students veterans active military we're
going to have Elijah Elijah paper
exclusively broadcasting from down in
Chas foreign country now yep I'm gonna
be talking about Chaz exactly we should
really more of a refugee camp pretty
much I'd like to put some of them in
cages and then we're also going to be
talking about racial art Brooks the
Atlanta shooting that obviously
transpired this weekend and why most of
what you know is incorrect
along with Co vid contact tracing and
how it does not apply to Kent Contra of
course contact okay can i correct that
what it only applies to certain protests
that's true
other ones it doesn't apply come on
there's a barber get up
he said the protests and we all know
what that means yeah there are no other
protests is that is that a pair of
clippers set phaser to gun yeah Cove it
reads the sign okay subscribe to crowd
or bits of course and check in every day
if you're not subscribe to the channel
hit notifications um also my question of
the day as we discussed justice and we
will move forward cuz we shard Brooks of
course we have Chazz if we move toward a
defunding police state there's a genuine
question of what I want to do is walk
this through tweet me a desk router or
will actually will take your live chats
of course supposedly at the blaze but I
would like to hear from people who are
more left-leaning because I think it's
important that we take the most extreme
examples and then kind of frame
so if we have no police defund the
police which is an extremist example to
us or as some people know at the DNC
platform what do you think will happen
right we've talked about likely
vigilante justice and at that point what
do you think the penalty or treatment
should be for the worst offenders among
us so let's take an extreme example you
don't like the police but what should
the penalty be for example like child
abusers child molesters right we all
agree universally the worst people among
us Aurel what should the penalties be
for them and what do we do in an
entirely lawless State we'll get to that
second look we have CNN right now let's
check in with whoever this is make it
successfully to the other side as a
complete person you know to your point
you say I know that all of you agree
that what has happened is horribly
unfair but most of you don't also have
to carry the grief that those of us with
black skin have to figure out how to
navigate a caveat during the I don't
agree I am exhausted I will say very I
do not agree that it was completely
unfair I agree that it's unfortunate but
what happened with racial art Brooks was
not completely unfair and I don't think
that officer should be fired
we'll get into why in a little bit but
first actually we need to correct some
issues that the media gets wrong always
always and last week they announced that
oh I should say half-asian we're bill
rich later you didn't tell me the show's
gonna be 45 hours correct everything
well every now we're sure they're
selective and the facts they present
we're selective and which ones we choose
to give our time amen otherwise we just
show up like like Rip Van Winkle and
instead of a nap but just in a chamber
with CNN it's uh it's off just come out
going spinning golden ooh yarn that's
not even my fairy tale what happened so
what are we correcting today yes well
first off let me correct myself
Gerald a is here for the black haired
audio a half asian on your bill Richmond
cops is not cancelled okay wrong it has
been reformatted and because of our
sizable audience they've asked us to be
those who exclusively sort of let people
know so this is actually an inclusive
look at a new upcoming episode of
reformatted cops
tonight are no comms
[Music]
yeah whatever
[Music]
No
Just Giving hurry up open up Ken hurry
up hurry open it up I just need like
gazing into a crystal ball interesting
like it
yeah these does shoot that shoots that's
the wrong word by the way a little
higher I also read tea leaves pretty
good I don't like doing the palms
because clammy
so the Atlanta shooting obviously I want
to make sure I get his name right
because these sometimes run to get
Rashard Brooks obviously is the the
trend that's been on everyone's lips
let's be clear we obviously want a
police force where as few people as
possible
dottie appeared the hands of the police
yeah period yeah whatever race of
whatever Rhea black white red yellow
First Nation yellow two-spirit no one
okay I don't know what it is they just
did the black trans lives matter and I
was like yeah whatever the lighter trans
lives matter okay I mean we kind of
thought that was covered under all lives
matter but you said that was racist and
so let's just run through all the lives
that matter that way we can do the same
it's like you know we do need to
abbreviate remedy it's getting so
complicated reberty is the soul of wit
or racist so gift it the lines have been
drawn place your bets now race yard
Brooks this was trending everywhere and
it's still remarkable to me that a lot
of people have not seen the full context
of the clip yeah
really wish that the man had not been
shot but I also wish that the media had
actually done their job and I also wish
that the local Wendy's hadn't been
torched and so the hashtag of course and
the original narrative which was pushed
out by Stacey Abrams
with whom I placed a bet by the way come
on her back yeah was a completely
unarmed entirely peaceful black man shot
by the everything about that including
unarmed in this case is wrong here's the
clip Wendy's drive-through for nope
for no good reason shut him I saw y'all
talking in for Noemi minutes dude
unarmed non-fatal nothing wrong with how
he conducted himself whatsoever what
will you pull up in gone dude okay now
none of this is to say if someone acts
inappropriately right or violently
assaults or punch officers in the face
and steal throw up and none of that is
to say that they deserve to die okay but
I do want to correct did nothing wrong
nothing at all and you pull a gun for no
reason and that video and that narrative
was retweeted by many elected officials
who also support says that will talk
about a little bit so there are multiple
angles I do warn you snot a trigger
warning it's an actual rating warning if
you have children but this is the
footage of what led up to Rashard being
shot reaching for the Taser right there
it's being told by Rossum over
[Music]
there's a punch thrown offs are on his
head on concrete
stop fighting there's another punch
there's another punch nothing has a run
tased running and then I think we have
the long shot hey bro we got kid well I
do understand the concern that you have
kids the primary concern is not being
shot by someone aiming it back at the
officer
yeah um by the way the way but right
before we got to that clip they were
showing him being handcuffed yes well
that's something that's very important a
lot of people miss as well so it was 20
thought it was tweeted out I don't
member it might have been ted Lieu that
i'm sorry
LuAnn hang my cousin no it it's no
reflection on you by the way I do want
to know if people at respectfully
tim-tim pool or Nagato mr. pool I
appreciate you if he regrets the gang
thing he should at this point oh my god
mr. Coolio because now yang is jumping
on the social justice warrior bandwagon
at every possible turn we thought he was
reasonable it turns out that's not the
case so the narrative was set hey this
is actually a responsible citizen who
pulled over because he was inebriated to
try and sleep it off well sure except
that's not what happened this is a guy
who passed out because of God knows was
what was in his system in the current
Wendy's drive-thru line just like just
foie gras are dragging mufflers like
just married behind a car exactly this
guy pulled over because he was hungry if
if he hadn't passed out he would have
been on the road driving some rent drunk
and I think we have tweet ringer the
other that they tweeted out that he was
pulled over for falling asleep in his
car no no actually he was falling asleep
for I think with another clip here right
okay so I'm confused all this is a long
shot so he didn't fall asleep in his car
and really anyone who's ever been
affected by drunk driving knows like the
what can happen from drunk driving knows
you don't get to the Wendy's parking lot
drunk without having driven right right
well god knows what reporting in there
Arnold Palmer's yeah I mean delicious
thing anytime I ask for coffee on Sweden
they can't figure it out so I assume
there's a little bit of wormwood liquor
in there probably some delicious but but
he literally in the state of Georgia the
way that the law is written is you have
to be in physical control of a vehicle
so the thing that they were there is a
sleep count so being asleep in the the
point being that yes if you're asleep
and you're driving a vehicle you have a
problem if you're in a parked vehicle in
a place that makes it indicate that
indicates that you had to have driven
there and you are in that moment drunk
yes you could prove I was sober I got
here I started drinking I'm sleeping it
off and now I'm driving so in which case
you should so thank you for advocating
that you should always keep an open
alcohol container in your car because
it's the lesser charge games like I got
you sober and then mr. Jameson said what
like McDonald's does some reddit they've
done some renovations it's a cool spot I
came up prove it so there's Wendy's
though let's go to the next rule if I
don't get this clip this clip is what
this is the long shot yeah ok this is
the clip is a long shot by the way this
is important as to the unarmed portion
again warning that this is where the man
is shot there's a long shot
now that explosion is important because
that's when injuries occur in sports
you've heard of pulling your punches
right you've heard of the idea of oh
this is the whole clip again yeah it
pulls I'm gonna see the long shot as to
what he does and where he aimed the
officers with
by the way people have died from that on
concrete being spiked on their head so
right there he tried to shoot them with
their own taser now here he's running
long shot long shot running it back ok
then he gets shot no obviously we would
prefer if this man was not shot we don't
need a full body cam footage we don't
even other-- angle of it that being said
this myth that this was a man who did
absolutely nothing wrong was entirely
peaceful and unarmed he was a correction
your honor he wasn't armed until he beat
the hell out of a police officer stole
two police officers stole their taser
and aimed it at than I've heard the
argument well a tasers a non-lethal
weapon okay then first why would you
advocate it in place of a gun for women
when it comes to rape defense and
someone could be on PCP who are
impervious to pain yeah second what is a
Taser designed to do because you want
officers at least you did to have tasers
instead of firearms right even though
it's non deadly what does it do
absolutely it's designed to incapacitate
so what is the danger in incapacitating
an officer with his own weapon where he
also has a deadly weapon do we have any
proof here that officers have been
harmed irreparably by their own tasers
here's some overlays it's actually very
common it happens all the time let's
also keep in mind if we're trying to
talk about being sympathetic to all
parties involved the second officer is
the one who shot to defend his officer
was fired I think it's absolutely wrong
I think this is a I think it's an
unfortunate scenario this is not a
lynching this is not somebody who went
out to harm a black guy you're an
officer and you're getting out you've
just been spiked on your head and you
see your fellow officer running and some
guy in the dark you don't kill you can't
identify they're aiming a gun at your
partner now perfect reaction no of
course not we've talked about better
training but is it outside of the realm
of possibility in a split second after
being punched in the face having your
bell rung potentially being out on your
feet that you think someone's about to
shoot your buddy no I I think this is
there I don't I have a problem with
somebody losing their life always right
I always hate it right we've said that a
million times but if this is not a case
where you get to defend your own life as
a police officer I really don't know
what is this person could have just
not resisted when they were cuffing him
he could have availed himself of the
criminal justice system and said I was
wrongfully cuffed I was wrongfully
arrested instead he started fighting and
winning there's no difference - there's
also a big difference between look
there's a big demon hey hey hey offs
payment listen can we just calm it and
all right putting your arms in and
explore yeah that's that sucker punch
which by the way we videotaped over here
at videotape we filmed the tape and
broadcast several officers got punched
in the face exact that's with intent to
cause serious harm and you know anyone
who knows this think of think of a rope
right this is why you warm up in sports
same thing in football half the me go
from zero to 60 same thing if you
actually even if you watch combat
competition a lot of the time if it's
sparring you don't do that what you
typically do is you've heard of pulling
your punches you know ease into it you
go slow because there's no way to
control that velocity that's designed to
generate as much inertia as humanly
possible think of it like a rope if the
Rope is already somewhat tight right you
can play tug-of-war okay going back and
forth no one gets hurt if it's an
entirely loose rope you say okay
everybody go a hundred percent on three
- yeah that's how people get hurt
yeah that's specifically let me be
really clear here as well we're gonna
get to a mod arborea video that only has
a hundred thousand plays by the way his
previous interaction with officers I am
a white guy basic [ __ ] pumpkin spice
latte of people default can anyone here
picture a world where I get so high
and/or drunk whatever it is we don't
know yet that I pass out in a Wendy's
drive-thru right fight officers punched
them in the face repeatedly spike one on
his head steal someone's taser try and
run aim it back at him fire and I not
get shot I cannot picture a world where
that doesn't happen I can't so I think
it's important to I think it's racially
motivated no no I think it's heat of the
moment incredibly violent in a way that
you should never interact with your
fellow man let alone
officer motivated also this is proof of
will go to a monarchy a little bit it's
just like the Cova deaths right people
out there think that people are dropping
like flies like everyone in this room
from Corona but no the average age of a
corona virus death is older than life
expectancy these are people who have
asthma who have cancer who have diabetes
who are morbidly obese the same
with these officer deaths 19 last sorry
9 last year of black unarmed men who
were shot by police officers this
wouldn't even be a part of that
statistic because you are not unarmed 19
white guys yeah and most of them when
we've gone through them I don't know if
the black lives matter video has been
banned from YouTube yet good chance it
has been are like this the idea that
it's just hey officer here's my license
here's my what bang my Benedict yeah
yeah if you could pick one that's the
one that would be the hero that's the
one that would be the mural this is not
a scenario where that is the case you
were about to say yeah I wonder what the
the Mayor of Atlanta actually called for
the firing of the police officer I
wonder what her response would have been
to the officers like okay in the
training class this is what's happening
here's what you do I wonder what she
would have said because we had already
tased him we had gone all the way up to
tasing and it didn't have any effect he
was still running he was still fleeing
he still turned around to try to aim the
Taser back at the other cop to get him
keep by the way keep in mind in this
bill you can talk to this they didn't
shoot him
at any point was just ringing away only
after he aims the gun went bad did they
shoot him right that's the only way they
kept running I doubt that the firing
would have happened that would have just
and this way I can shoot and give you my
back right and that's what the guy is
doing
I can shoot like this as a matter of
fact that's like that's why you watch
you know Floyd Mayweather he's got that
Philly show he stands like this what's
going on [ __ ] what's going cuz you can
barely hit up now it works with him
because he's four foot nothing in the
six of the 14 ounce gloves covers entire
dome Tyson Fury's not gonna have a shot
because he's a man but he's good my
point is it can't just be he was shot in
the back they didn't and they had ample
time to shoot him in the back
they didn't until he aimed right their
own weapon at them now taser granted the
other guy doesn't necessarily know at
that point you know just trying to be
sympathetic everybody involved and I
think it's really difficult this is why
you have officers who resigned in
Minneapolis where you have officers all
SWAT team members of that that of
whatever you know sergeant who knelt
with the pro they feel as though they
cannot protect themselves and it's less
likely that they go home to their
families now and nobody wants someone be
vote low but make sure we're gonna pay
them less just yes
peanuts oh that's less money for
training - yes coz less training this
yeah well we need right and less money
for guns because we just won't be any
guns and whatever any guns yeah no more
guns after this no more Tasers and no
chuckles no nightstick see so what's the
message if a guy beats up a cop and
turns this is my concern two turns back
in Ames
our police officer supposed to succumb
hope it's not a good get him next time
lost another one is lesson we want to
teach people that if you are black have
committed felonies and don't want to be
arrested that cops can't arrest you hmm
yes yes is that the message yes well
here's my yeah that is the message
unequivocally the message is you're
supposed to be the voice of real and
everyone go commit no crimes by officers
but anyone else good to go yes okay
pretty much and now let me say this this
weekend sir I'm just a little bit fired
up this weekend I placed a bet with
Stacey Abrams I think we have the tweet
right here ricin hmm how much you want
to bet that a guy violently arresting
violently resisting arrest at this point
that there's more of the story I bet my
entire social media plans Twitter
Facebook Instagram this show YouTube
channel against her likely candidacy for
VP probably should look - but point is I
would have bet the house against a ring
from a cracker jack box
that there were some priors involved and
or other chemical enhancements and so
this guy didn't want to go back to the
clink which again is relevant because
that's one of the first things police
officers take into consideration yeah if
they pull over a perp they run the
plates and they go oh my gosh this guy
is a violent criminal now if they're
just someone with some minor infractions
of course that wouldn't be the case but
as it relates to race chard Brooks let's
say the police officers run the plate
what would they find let's go to the
tale of the tape
[Music]
all right that's a very long tape list
and again this matters because people
think that it's just rent random black
men walking the streets are not safe
from our officers including black
officers who by the way make up a higher
percentage of the force than they do the
average American population well they
used to we'll see how that holds
something about Tommy's cabin I called
Tommy anything that would give officers
possible he's been incarcerated twice
now a granted it could be because he's
sold like counterfeit tickets to the
school talent that's true
what is obstructing one is obstructing a
law enforcement officer okay I'm really
a big deal I guess you know we don't
care about that
then there's criminal interference and
government property sentence lengths so
the first one had 12 months this had
five years what does that mean
interference and not a no idea then the
other one is so idea theft by wreck
stolen props seven years as a sentence
length oh wow that's crazy so let's look
at the next one here and this is where
it gets interesting and Rashard Brooks
the hero over whom you you mean you
black white red yellow people in Atlanta
torched the Wendy's because justice put
one on the scoreboard for you you're
winning over Americans hearts and minds
then we have a family violence battery
oh yeah that's pretty bad yes sound good
and after that we have false
imprisonment which is seven years but
here's the weird thing about the false
imprisonment we don't have all of the
case files here yeah it occurred on the
same day as cruelty to children so the
same crime that day one carries seven
years one carries another year cruelty
to children and false imprisonment so I
think we're talking about there's a high
likelihood that he may be kidnapped a
child yeah it's not uncommon to have
those two together because of the fact
that when for example if you don't have
custody over a child and you put that
child into your car or you just take
them away from the other parent who does
have custody and especially if there's
any kind of physical violence like
pushing the other bride away that's how
you can I mean there's a whole variety
of ways that it could have happened but
it's not uncommon to see those two
together when you have a case of a child
being taken away from okay
whose guard yeah and then I guess the
more recent one is just simple better
simple simple better not a lithium not
even an energizer generic battery but
this is this is why I ask don't know if
we have any of those chats from people
what do you think the punishment should
be for people who are cruel to children
people who are whether they're child
molesters whether they abuse children
whether they kidnap children because
that's one that we all agree is
unacceptable to say why for the same
reasons that PETA get really mad about
chinchilla coats in that children are
helpless right people feel really bad
for the most vulnerable among us which
is also why interesting nearly enough
older people support not defunding cops
because they need cops to protect them
yeah so what do we do what do you think
happens if we defund all the police if
we end up like Chaz which is what we're
going to get to in a moment
no police you end up with a vigilante
State ok how do you think child abusers
and molesters fare in a vigilante State
even people we're not yeah what's in
Kersey what's his name from Death Wish
Kersey it's not not Kersey Gardner I
don't know they don't kill them so
Hersey jail the guy that goes around
taking them out put this way how do you
think child abusers people who are cruel
to children fare in a vigilante State
this guy got off father positively easy
with police officers by the way what
happened there isn't that much worse
than if you did that in a bar fight yeah
we hold our officers to a higher
standard I absolutely understand that
but the fact that this officer was fired
the fact that this story was meted as a
man who was peaceful who had peacefully
pulled his car aside in a Wendy's
parking lot now and was then shot when
he did absolutely nothing wrong
when in fact it's a man who did
everything wrong who violently assaulted
officers who did steal a weapon who was
armed who did aim it at the cops and has
a history of cruelty to sorry [ __ ]
children everything about everything
about now as obviously we would rather
the cops didn't have to shoot anybody of
course with Ray chard Brooks everything
about this man's adult history is ugly
yeah and if you want that to be your
representative whether whether you're a
white member white virtue stealing
member of black lives matter or a black
person everything about that man is ugly
yeah well then I think the cops in
Georgia I mean unless bill I mean it
unless there's any other legal thing
where he can go now if that guy acted it
responsibly as a police officer it
doesn't look your
responsible at all they talked with him
for like 10 or 15 minutes before this
made him go through what you know trying
to see if he was sober or not right
going through all this and they were
totally fine with him nothing happened
until he escalated and tried to fight
them so that he wouldn't be arrested if
I was a cop in Georgia right now I'd be
like okay I can't defend my life that's
the message you just sent to me is that
I cannot defend my life and I have to
put it on the line every single day I'm
done I'm out I'm sorry I'm off that I'm
off the job yeah it's actually happened
it's actually it's almost it's worse
than that when you dig into it because
when you when you look at the let's just
say the initial interaction should the
police have come to deal with someone
who had passed out and appeared to be
drunk again let's take the circumstances
it's the middle of the night fast food
cars running guys passed out in it
sleeping people are driving around right
now what was Wendy supposed to do there
they called the cops what were they
supposed to do George Zimmerman's
supposed to call the time were they
supposed to go out there and you know
confront the guy that's no that's a
little bit Abrams advocated if citizens
would pull him over and give him a glass
of water
really what if the guys on PCP you are
told not to pull his immerman you are
told to call the cops and so then so
then you say okay well you're not you
were supposed to call the cops okay I
guess we don't call the cops now all
right so the cops are there the cops
pull them out and you know get him out
of the line pull him on they start
talking to him and they choose in that
moment to talk with him about what he's
doing and it's in that moment he can
give the explanation since in fact he
doesn't during the course of that 20
minutes it's clear that he's under the
influence of something else right he got
there right so yeah not only from the
talking but from the sobriety test in
the other ports they still don't go
after him arrest him anything they
continue to talk with him so now the
lesson is no no no you should never
should have talked to him in the first
place you should have just sent him on
his way which is literally what Mothers
Against Drunk Driving has been saying is
the opposite of what you're supposed to
do right right you have to punish him
because they're not just doing it that
night they're doing it multiple times
they're doing it all the time and maybe
they didn't kill anyone in that moment
they kill someone later and so that's
why officers are allowed in many states
to be able to pull you over even if you
make it home and you pass out in your
driveway right right and two hours later
they come and they test your BAC and
it's under the level if they can prove
where you were before that can be
evidence circumstantial evidence of
committing I got pulled over once when
doing
nothing wrong because I was driving in a
big in a crowded area i was los angeles
and i had a rental car now this happened
two different times by the way once am i
got it is your white one time i got it
to you one time I did I was just driving
down to I didn't turn the lights on and
the cop said that's actually one of the
most common pullovers because of drunk
drivers they vary yeah very rarely when
the whole everything in the dashboard is
on it was a it was a Nissan Versa Nissan
Versa because these should be automatic
or nothing comes on don't give me the
appearance of automatic headlights no
okay that's what often happens with
drunk driving it was explained to me
actually our friend Jordan II said yeah
that's how they catch a lot of drunk
drivers yeah people just don't turn on
their lights and I didn't have a problem
that make sense you might think I'm
drunk you know what I come from a place
that isn't nearly as well-lit as Los
Angeles here out by a Manhattan Beach
and thank you let me go on my merry way
let's go let's continue on this by the
way because everyone's forgotten about
this Ahmad Arbor II um the two white
guys who shot him by the way who did
call the cops but they didn't wait for
the cops so that was a problem there was
this man was in a neighborhood and he
was going through a house under
construction and granted of course of
course we don't think that this man
should have been shot
Ahmad our burry in that instant yeah
it's sad it's tragic but you do see a
tussle that happens with a man who
didn't seem like he had intent to commit
a hate crime because he called the cops
but then the cops didn't get there in
time and now we know that the cops would
have been just as vilified as the guys
who committed the alleged hate crime
while calling the cops so this is an
example where um no and no one has
talked about this it only had a hundred
thousand plays or a hundred fifty
thousand plays yesterday can pay dirt
compared to the Ahmad R burry
interaction that you saw which had
millions again what kind of tenor in
tone while we're talking about police
officers who need to de-escalate all the
time well is there also a duty on
citizens do we have a responsibility to
not try and instill fear of death in
officers by I don't know reaching in our
pockets or sing and going to fu up boy
which I know sounds like an exaggeration
but here's the interaction of Ahmad abri
with police officers that you haven't
seen before you want no one what you
keep around your pocket I'll tell you
why I'm here man I'll tell you why
because this area is known for drug
activity listen you're back
some units waste
tell me another unit and you go get
effed up that's a threat copy them do
anything by the way they don't give him
a ticket think I heard him utter his
radio melon another unit don't reach the
car man that guy doesn't know at that
point that he's already checked the
weapon oh it isn't morning okay I don't
think we need a warning at that point if
someone's reaching in their pocket
that's easy warning in that sample time
yeah now here's a beauty get a suspended
license your license is suspended so
technically you can't really drive the
car we'll go and get your hair man now
let me let me say something that might
be unpopular here I believe that
actually a mod armory in that instance
was given grace because of his race and
those cops didn't want to be in the
nightly news yeah at the very least that
looks illegally parked for being double
parked out of the line now how would I
know this have I had any experience with
driving on a suspended license and not
telling a cop that he was gonna get
effed up and running up on him several
times my hand in my pocket
no citizenry so what happened was
actually I was pulled over and this got
wiped because what happened was I had
gotten one ticket in my life at this
point yeah I had gotten it in Michigan
in my wife's car we weren't made at the
time in a town where I didn't live and
they sent the ticket to an address right
never been oh wow no idea what the
address was I don't know why that was
marked down and so what happened is I
would have already shot you at this
point
I never paid one ikut and I never got
pulled over again and then I got pulled
over and I said do you know your license
is suspended
I said no why I said you have a ticket
from whatever it was two years ago in
Ann Arbor Michigan and a speeding trap
with an angry lesbian cop but you know I
said no he goes yeah well you know what
you can't drive this car and at the time
I had a cameraman there he said so where
are you going well I was going that very
day to the Lansing protest where I was
repeatedly punched in the face I said
I'm going down to the Lansing State
Capitol he said all right well I need
you to switch out that man can drive the
car you can't drive the car and I'm
going to follow you to the Lansing
Capitol and by the way here's your
ticket and your court date that I had to
show up and that happened you get
tickets for driving on a suspended
license now they didn't give this guy
any kind of a ticket repeatedly walking
up on the officer repeatedly reaching
into his pocket I don't know if there's
any kind of a ticket you can give out
her advancing to a cop you're gonna get
[ __ ] up boy but it seems to me like at
the very least it's ill-advised and then
nothing for a suspended license or
illegally parked you know why because
it's probably a conversation this is me
speculating on do you want to be in the
nightly news for this disguise obviously
very irritated he's yelling at us he
just said he's gonna Fe it's gonna f me
up if we do anything just let him go
with a suspended license ya knows how
many more crimes can be committed yeah
absolutely I don't know the officer said
I mean I would say in that instance I
think they did what they would have done
in other situations and sometimes they
give grace and sometimes they don't
probably true but I don't think there's
any question that it doesn't come into
the mindset of an officer now now they
are forced to see race in every instance
because they know if for example racial
art Brooks had not had been non black
and I'm not even gonna say white right
I'm sorry non black because of yourself
right so myself right myself or my you
know my wife is Hispanic right I mean
hey let's go through so you know yeah me
okay great right I mean like you know I
would have I would have definitely been
shot by the way your wife is is
beautifully ethnic his wife has that
like a milk chocolate skin Wow
worse is like well what do we do we need
an Indonesian do we need someone who's
part Asian do we need say that we need
it we need biracial oh do it do it the
hell's a difference people gonna love
her right it's true I've never seen
their skin and I will say this okay is
this racist by design when someone has
darker skin and it's perfect I said like
look when you see like a black woman who
has perfect skin it is really a sight to
behold and we know this but
light backs differently on different
colors we had black people in this
studio where we had to change the
lighting it is strikingly pretty to me
and your wife isn't black obviously she
has darker skin and so when it's darker
you see that smoothness and it's very
pretty and so anyway his wife is very
pretty my wife always tells me that
Bills Bills wife is so pretty oh oh and
got more awkward our wives our secret
lesbianism Oh Gerald don't worry we
still think you're at least at or above
average looking yeah okay sorry
speak from personal experience as a
minority against whom I discrimination
was you know blob Priestley with the
railroads and I mean look I gotta tell
you I've been pulled over multiple times
I was in a neighborhood that I picking
up a friend on a Sunday for mock trial
practice in high school and I wasn't
parked in front of any particular house
and an officer came and you know ended
up I was just literally reading a book
and he came and we took me out of the
car and we had interaction he you could
tell he wasn't sure what was going on he
did the normal way of right kind of
standing back behind the wheel where he
could see my hands you know had me put
my hands on the steering wheel like on
the top I had them on the side my dad
just only like when you get pulled over
turn the car off turn the radio off roll
the windows down down the freeway pull
us far too far this time put your hands
on the steering wheel and I would just
had them on the side instead of on top
so he said put him on top took me out of
the vehicle I mean I I was been taken
out of a car on the highway and you know
I said oh I do have a firearm in the
back because I was going to my dad's
ranch during college and he was like I'm
gonna need to get out of the car Pat me
down I almost opened the back door of
his car he asked actually asked me to
get into the car into the police car so
I reached for the fact or but he was
like he screams no wise like there's a
canine back there I did not see the
warning sign that canine unit so we
ended up getting in the mighty different
bill yeah and in each of those instances
you know God got the ticket that you
know I deserved I mean I was you know
whatever I was doing the first one I
didn't get a ticket for doing because
there wasn't anything wrong he said
there had been robberies in the
neighborhood and I haven't seen that
your car around and you're not parked in
front of any particular house right I
was like yeah no I really do a master
well I don't know do you think you look
anything like this just a picture of mr.
Miyagi I know it was just Kim jong-il so
I get it in in these instances the
question is you know were other things
racially motivated right I mean that's
it's really what it comes down to but in
the instance of Rashard Brooks again
think about the all the moments when he
resisted arrest when he was punching
them repeatedly they did not take that
additional force they didn't even take
the force when he was running away with
their weapon they only took the action
in that moment at them when he aimed it
and in fact the direction on which he
aimed it was not just at the officer but
if the civilians who were in their
vehicles right and we're also feeling it
true and so again it I don't think
you're gonna eat you may even hear this
officer come and say in the heat of the
moment having looked back at it now I
regret that I was put in a situation
where I feared for other people's lives
and felt I needed to use my gun and
maybe in the cold light of day yeah I'm
not in that moment I would have chosen
something different but in that moment I
chose that because I was fearful for
people's lives and that was what I had
at my disposal that's almost like it's
their job to protect people's lives not
necessarily to only protect the life of
the child abuser yeah so everyone else
should be taken into consideration I
would you have to move on to the chest
thing but I will say this I do believe
that at this point race has taken in the
equation that I believe there is more
grace given to people who say you're
gonna be in the nightly news I'm gonna f
you up they go do we even if it's
entirely justified at this point well
does that qualified immunity tomorrow
talking about it there's no I'm just
gonna be thrown on new because no one
wants to deal with the backlash I know I
can speak from I know a lot of people
it's just anecdotal but that's what I
have in this instance is anecdotal I was
pulled over for a suspended license I
got zero grace whatsoever and I got a
ticket for I think going like four over
which I didn't even know you can do
let's move on to the some chazz chazz
run by mr. Roth razzmatazz chas rape is
what's going on in jazz right now this
is the area of the autonomous zone and
in Seattle and I do find this
interesting because this does just show
what a disconnect what the hell is that
on television that was just a well
that's the Wendy's
fired well and okay would be proud I
have a dream today that Dave's double
stack will no longer see through with
racial lens but a triple because what
kind of [ __ ] a double stack is
YouTube get two stories today YouTube
gets two stories I am an angry white man
oh boy
oh no here we go what are you gonna burn
down what does that mean it means that
in portrayed is an all right skinhead
that's what we got it's like a salt when
someone shows up to defend their own
property with a firearm like these
extreme right-wingers the
jack-in-the-box next door thought you
know we'd have a fire extinguisher I
don't think that's extremism any more
fires do spread so the coverage from the
media of Jews is it's been very peaceful
as a matter of fact this is something
that's very rare you know in politics
writing probably in law they tell you
don't speak in absolute right since it
don't say always never not at all but
the media coverage has quite literally
you will see a clip here that all city
officials have said that it's been
entirely peaceful and of course that's
been echoed everywhere in the media here
unless you think I like why do you
believe the president chose to talk
about domination in the face of what's
happening not just in your city but in
many instances when it comes to what the
remedy is for the unrest in the country
right now what do you think this is
about for him I think it shows a
complete lack of understanding and why
people are in the street there in the
street fighting a system of domination
and he doesn't understand that and his
response is always one that's bellicose
and militaristic but he doesn't honor
the military in that way either as
you've seen from the line of generals
that have disputed him so I think he
says marinate because he is totally does
not understand what is happening in
America and he is desperately trying to
start the old fights in the old
divisions that put him in power in the
first place how long do you think
Seattle and those few blocks looks like
this
I don't know we could have the Summer of
Love do we have that clip by the way
that I asked for the second clip so ah
let's go here so is it clip B but B
there's a little because clip B is the
police officer that I have here I want
to make sure we have the right clip no
all right all right
this is another clip mislabeled sir okay
there we go well city leaders
acknowledge that everything has been
peaceful and you continue to have this
street else I would like to do that
station you should know leaving the
precinct I got my decision you fought
for days to protect it I asked you to
stand on that line day in and day out to
be pelted with projectiles to be
screamed at threatened and in some cases
hurt then to have a change of course
nearly two weeks in it seems like an
insult to you in our community response
times for over 15 minutes now I'm on let
you go back to playing with your Tonka
trucks but do you know that what you did
was wrong pick you metal ladle because
I'm on beat yo ass last quote of her
saying that response time is tripled to
number one for rapes and burglaries I
couldn't find there's another clip of it
where she was on location reiterate on
that I couldn't find it anywhere ABC
News CNN CBS I went to Reuters couldn't
find it I could only find the written
articles of her quotes now why do you
think that is well we actually know the
answer to that Soledad O'Brien recently
came out and said that at CNN they
frequently would only light the right
black voice CNN and apparently the chief
of police in Seattle who is a woman of
color doesn't get to talk about it when
she's criticizing the mayor and sold out
of rhyme fakes like she can speak French
and so on no this is find it anywhere
and I know we're gonna have Elijah
Schaeffer up is going to be down
they're from one location but I would
like to show some if we can some b-roll
if you haven't seen b-roll at all or any
pictures of Chad's going on because this
is something that's very interesting to
me not only could you not find the
police speech only written articles Chaz
is the least democratic place in the
United States proportion this guy
Razzles Azzam razzmatazz whose apartment
has seized control no one voted for him
no one voted for this person the people
who live in this area right the people
who run businesses owned houses they're
now being asked for ID to enter and
leave their own dwellings well that's
not legal no one voted for that where
any of the Democratic Socialist right
Bernie Sanders what would democratic
socialism okay I still think that
socialism is bad even if you vote for it
but in this case people didn't even vote
for it it's a coup it's been seized by
effectively domestic terrorists where is
the DNC who are all about democracy at
this point you don't understand what a
constitution would represent a republic
is but in this case it couldn't be more
clear cut the people who live there the
people who built that city the people
who pay taxes had no say in being ruled
over by people who by the way
hilariously tried to create a garden and
the funniest story of all that's been
alight with comments about your inky
hands cheap suits that's it with cheap
suits no ma no no my handlers in the
Chinese government told me this would
really annoy you what I said no no it
won't be that effective they're like
very slow burn of a plan it really is it
should be more acute is my point
and something else too that's very
interesting to me well it's the least
democratic place in the United States a
couple of other things when they one of
their demands is d gentrification yes
how do you do that without segregation
[ __ ]
you stupid goofy dumb [ __ ] how do you
do geo gentrification unless you pull
like the black lives matter by the way
and just tell everyone else to the back
of the line white p.m. yeah I would
argue as racist also something
I find interesting this is the leftist
utopia is similar to Detroit we've
talked about that when the left gets
what they want this is what they want is
Chaz right Chaz is the left that's why
it's supported by the mayors that's why
it's supported by members of the DNC
people like ted Lieu again sorry
not all half is only half cousin
so what's interesting to me is this is
exactly what they want anyone out there
actually want to argue that this looks
more like a nudist hippie commune than
say East Berlin have you seen the
graffiti have you seen the trash have
you seen the fires and by the way that's
not really surprised because at any time
the left gets what they want
it's always the lesser Berlin it never
turns out any other way hey look CNN
right now just showing they were just
showing the end of that shooting didn't
show the lead up did they no interested
we have it they have access to it now
right I would hope we do everyone's had
access in Saturday afternoon and no one
has covered it um here's something else
before we go to Elijah Schafer who is
live for us down there they've also
something else to point out again then
it's just a mob that it's tyranny
improbably tyranny by the Mott it's just
as much as a mob mob from the government
that's right tyranny from the government
tyranny from the government coming from
the government it's just too severe if
it's coming from a mob especially the
government that's designed to protect
you from tyranny doesn't step and help
you it's still tyranny if you have to
show ID to get in and out of your
dwelling and you have to pay this mob of
people who are running roaming the
streets unfettered simply to run your
business that is tyranny and we in the
United States do not do tyranny so it is
the government's role to step in and
stop mob based tyranny in case you don't
believe what I'm saying here's I believe
a business owner who's been shaken down
by the mob we've heard I think we have
armed people patrolling yeah hope is
that clear not working yeah all right
stop that clipper doing over to the
other clips alright basically what the
Mafia was doing it was a shakedown for
protection money and them all the mob
bosses near like come on you started a
new country and took our model yeah and
you're not in trouble
wait why about touching this pen again
why are you
got him by the way that garden don't
lick it wouldn't be promoted so high a
communist party because of this you know
what's funny the only person I ever the
only two novelty shops that have ever
known in my life for owned by Asians I'm
about Chinese men two of them were
really funny one guy made me afraid of
Chinese people do you know why I'll tell
you I'll tell you remind me to go ahead
why I was afraid that this story yeah
it's not racist at all I just created a
gross generalization about old Asian
manner and novelty shops for years to
come
let's go then since I'm not sure about
the clips further than working we have
Elijah Schaeffer do we have him here
live from jazz I just like saying it
that way Elijah how are you sir we're
doing okay we've had some issues here
with clips but you needn't worry
yourself about that also an ink debacle
huh where are you right now are you down
in Chas okay and what have you seen I
think we have a some clips from his
Instagram right because we weren't able
to get the footage that you send this
born in touch but let's really quickly
that you tell us what it is that you've
been seeing on the ground and then we'll
show some of the footage basically what
I've been seeing on the ground here is
there's two types of chance there's the
chance during the day where the Daily
Beast were CNN where everybody else
likes to show and then there's the
chance last night but one of my
stringers and a friend of mine named
Kalin he's from Kalin on Twitter he was
recording an altercation with Raz Simone
and one of his one of his crew members
they grabbed they they told him hand
over your phone hand over your stuff or
if you don't then we're gonna beat the I
don't like I say but beat the [ __ ] out
of you
you can Anthony said no he goes no I'm
not gonna give it over so they grabbed
him by the by the by the show
punched him in the head he tried to run
and then they cornered him on the street
he was screaming out for help and then
they told him no you can't leave you
have to come to an interrogation tent so
they now have interrogation tens they
now have interrogation places where you
are forced to go to be interrogated to
see what you were doing and they said we
have reports that you are filming our
security plans and this is this is
during the moment when Rathbone and his
crew chased down a supposed leader of a
local business as they broke in instead
of fire searching the bags and also you
know basically a Ewing Gestapo work and
so there's it is fully developed into a
police state here and they don't talk
about that during the day while
everyone's smoking pot and having sex
with each other in dirty tents listen
that does sound like the Summer of Love
so basically it's the police without any
accountability or rule of law do you
have any footage of that at all since
you said your friend had a camera or did
they end up yet the police were involved
so it's an open issue so the police
can't hide in in a construction site the
John Brown Gun Club actually chased them
down in full black block and so the John
Brown Gun Club which people don't know
is related to the ice attacked the fire
attack so they're related to domestic
terrorism on on federal property and
they're doing they're doing such a deep
we see here that I was and was able to
go undercover pretend like I was part of
the John Brown Gun Club because I have
this really sexy you know domestic
terrorist looks like a wanderlust it
doesn't look like East Berlin to the
beaches has right now which I want to
show you we have footage there is
footage of that it's on Jack vasilevich
on that from Kaelin as well on Twitter
and more is coming out but here's the
point there is a lot of freedom to do
what you want here unless of course that
is talking positively about Trump
or if it's about filming what's really
going on that's why you're not seeing a
lot for the mainstream media because
they know if they show what happens
they'll get taken out but I will tell
you that someone when I got out of my
over gave me some magic mushrooms I'm
not going to take them this is the
beaches here
it's really beautiful by the way it goes
perfectly with the mushrooms the whole
leaving Las Vegas yeah just like
scattered the ashes of lost communists
dreams someone else yeah have you heard
about it let me see the gardens eh can
you take us to the gardens because I saw
pictures in it about made me I'm gonna
had to get new pants I pissed myself so
hard laughing you are about one minute
away from the best experience all right
so listen as you walk I'll talk a little
bit so so far what we have is we have a
peaceful commune where there's
leadership that has not been elected
don't have law enforcement you have no
rule of law but you do have effectively
a police state and you don't have
freedom of the press or freedom of
speech so these people are definitively
less free than anywhere else in oh I
would say the surrounding country but
they're country America and pretty soon
the red white and blue will put a boot
in their ass and make sure they know we
do also have some clips that he says
this morning a Mont okay so listen hey
Elijah hold there be safe being
ridiculous just pretend like you took
the mushrooms gonna show some clips real
quick to the audience let's see that
let's see the gardens yeah I like this
place a lot this is the garden I don't
know it's kinda probably backwards but
it's this garden is for black and
indigenous and and their plant allies
this is the black indigenous apply all I
want that's growing really well Hassan
what happens if you're white and you
plant in the garden or take from the
garden well well you need to come to
this garden over here with the wind
chimes it's the wind chimes one so yeah
it's a good community we is we're in its
we are enough straight up
there it is like and we have the future
that's a future Sun thing and we are
this is where we are and then we have a
message what are they growing in the
gardens Elijah tell me what it's a good
question
orchids so we got orchids okay and
that's why by the way the local National
Guard and Fire Department have had to
bring in food supply yes we can't film
volunteers no one wants to be filmed
though so I'm just filming the plants
themselves okay we have hay and then we
have a lot of these I know many things
the antifa flower gardens here what are
they grow pretty cool um you know that's
all I can read it here we go herbs Greek
oregano I don't know what you I don't
know Greek oregano is this one okay well
the essentials it's great yeah so you
can go to the clips but I'm gonna while
you're showing the clips I'm gonna go
walk over to the next section okay all
right we'll check back in with you so
you can put some oregano Wow over the
food that is care flown into your
autonomous state so your MRE will be
tasty you know what this Jimmy Jones
could really use some anarchist oregano
a little Greek zing
don't they of oregano Jimmy Jones I
don't want that corporatist oregano
where'd you get that where'd you get the
oregano seat
Oh Green Giant [ __ ] yeah all right
you can't go you can't go to Home Depot
you can't go to the you can't go to that
what is it botanical section because you
know let's show some clips really quick
to the audience again don't believe me
believe your lyin eyes and ears that's
what stupid looks like that
[Laughter]
that was the good guy the black guy with
the flag that was stolen and he was run
out more birdies hey what sexual
harassment yeah I guess I don't have
mental health counseling down there
either haven't gone to that funding yet
no this is it attacking them so dear
fund the police and put the funding into
social workers who sexually harassed
disturbed at his Christian extremists
that guy was a seemed like every rapture
street preacher he wasn't hurting
anybody annoy sexual harassment I hope
we find that guy who did it and I hope
the charges are brought at some point I
hope charges are brought against all of
these people and you know I will I'll go
back to my opinion will go off YouTube
really quickly but Elijah back to you
sir show us what you got and then we
will go up a little bit because yeah
yeah I'm sure I got the note look we're
at the no cop co-op so is it the
interrogation tent co-op okay I think
that's the medic tent actually but we
have I mean you can get literally
whatever you want here there are beans
and canned foods and snacks it's all
free - you could just you can just like
they're all this looks like a can you
just can you just take take something
right now see what they do
yeah it's really great just take they'll
give you anything you want take care of
you it's really really nice and there's
the barricades and also show you so
right here you have the anti-colonialism
conversation center and then that's next
for the feelings feelings and emotions
tent which is nearby and this is the
last part when I leave you it's ya know
I've been
last night I people got into an argument
I looked for a water and then I got they
only had beer
so which they brewed themselves no doubt
oregano and but then they blessed me
with a really good beer the Hard Rock
Rolling Rock which is essentially water
right so now I'm not the police this is
the police precinct right here this is
pretty you'll see right I don't know
this is a mirrored so it's pretty crazy
but you got the Seattle police right
here and it's kind of in pretty not the
worst condition I've ever seen in my
life it'll look it's pretty good if you
yeah check it out are people sleeping in
those tents or those just like poop
tents oh no those are the citizens of
Chows there there there we don't we
don't have names for them yet but if
your viewers went out of comment and
give their best name for the village
homes we haven't been able to uh to come
up with you yeah but people are just
camping around
how about [ __ ] does that work is
that a sit or is that tanking after that
this is this is the police precinct that
uh all the names to b2q sega's still in
pretty good shape your best your best
mr. Gorbachev tear down whatever this is
it's more than all this is this is all
gonna be this is all gonna right here to
go use the restroom and the the code to
get in was one three one two which is
ACAB all cops are bastards so okay we
all know if we're looking for a place to
take a steaming pile in Seattle Elijah
thank you so much and please do keep us
posted anything you have want to amplify
be safe brother where's the best place
for people to find your work as well
yeah yeah yeah so the best place if
you're if you're watching now go to
youtube.com slash slightly offensive
that's youtube.com slash so
offensive and you can also find the ad
alleges Schaefer on on Twitter but also
know there's gonna be a bunch of
extended footage and cuts there's also a
walkthrough right now and end-to-end
unedited walkthrough of the of Chazz on
my youtube channel right now that you
can watch with narrow need to see the
whole place all right Thank You Elijah
we appreciate a brother we must go and
to everyone else watching on YouTube
right now we have some tweets to get
you're also gonna be playing as a token
character Vulcan character or
depressions YouTube piss off my club
only now